natalia and her husband are finally
moving back into their home
not long ago there was russian artillery
all around here
and the scars from the fighting remain
when the russian troops came in they had
to move their entire life into this
basement
there they waited for one long month
and each time they had to emerge
together essentials they put their lives
at risk
i had to walk out to bring my neighbor
milk then a russian soldier asked me
where my husband is i told him my
husband cannot walk then he says come
out into the road and points a rifle at
me and speaks through the radio the
response on the radio was this is not
her and he left
as i walked back to the basement i was
trembling
the town of brujanka was taken by the
russian forces on the 28th of february
the fifth day of the war
as a strategic town that leads to the
ukrainian capital cave it was caught in
the crossfire of heavily armed forces
from both sides
since the russian forces left this town
the scale of destruction is just now
being revealed as we came into borjanka
we have seen many buildings heavily
shelled and collapsed authorities say
people still remain beneath the rubble
and the residents we have spoken to say
they have lived in terror
zvitlana is one of many who lost loved
ones in this town
the night her neighbor's house was
attacked her brother died
svetlana tells us he was scared to
death my brother was paralyzed on the
22nd of march the neighbor's house
exploded and he had a heart attack and
died
the risk of having a proper funeral was
too great that people had to bury the
dead in their backyards
look this is my neighbor his family is
not here but he was shot and this is
where he was buried
she takes us to the makeshift grave of
her brother
svetlana says now she must give her
brother a proper burial
but as she agrees his loss she also
faces an uncertain future
resulter al jazeera brujanka